the fact that we hear the culminating
moment is like how do you get back to
the normality of it all right like
what's the new normal for for me
it doesn't exist without the association
of the war that is
ongoing um it's not
it hasn't subsided
you know it's just the relocation of
some things and we're not gonna get into
it but
you know it's it's an ongoing thing so
for me
you know i
and i was lucky that peter was with me
on this like i made that commitment like
that we are you know working on bar nova
27 my organization we're pushing out aid
we're working on other ways of getting
other things into the country and where
it needs it's needed
you know we're working on
uh developing
livable towns makeshift towns that can
maybe serve as something else
try to attract technology you know 3d
printing and so on so
you know
this is where i'm dedicating myself but
i think it's very important to also make
sure that people don't forget about it
you know i realized when i got home
that this is so far away
and it is hard to
retell the story over and over and so
you know i'm just using this opportunity
to also say like it's going on right now
people are just now starting to need
even more help and we should
you know stay with it to get the phone
call and to call him and see him like
frantically packing his bags like trying
to get out of the hotel was just
like
i had a heart attack nearly like i had
to sit myself down and like calm down
for him and you know then the next what
eight days that you were there
eight days
were
life-changing
absolutely life-changing i mean i
literally wrote him a text
almost a good buy text like if something
happens oh don't make me cry
no but look it's you know the
perspective is is
it happened uh for a reason right
and so
again it's not to use you know i guess
that's what happens with the sean fan
when he had the revelation he had to do
core right and and be a part of
something bigger you know with me it was
with with jim global empowerment mission
you know the scene the magnitude of what
bethany frankel was able to do with be
strong and how they were able to build
an incredible infrastructure and i
thought about it i'm like you know i
have the ian my dad myself and val were
born at baranova 27 that's our address
so you know who bought us to do this on
a bigger level and and bring more
awareness it's it's our you know it's my
burden to bear it's my you know flag to
sort of like bear
i am um
you know my brother and i are lucky
recipients of our parents decision in
the 90s to immigrate
you know and where we left we left the
exact same regime
that's you know ukraine is fighting
right now and so the irony of being back
in that place
in the time of war when my parents
decision was for us to escape the war
that was just there was a lot of stuff
going on yeah my dad's actually flying
over now like in the next couple of days
uh so we're continuing our presence and
just making sure that you know we're
still developing our logistics you know
it's very hard getting the right things
at the right time
you know to the people that need him and
so that's what i'm working out the next
level for me is to be able to
you know answer a call within a you know
24 hours
and be able to deliver whatever's needed
i'm lucky we're i think i'm lucky with
the foundation that we have the type of
relationship that we have and i felt
really bad because she was telling me
not to go i saw was the every you know
sane person but you know i was i was i
was offered advice you know and i
followed those advice and you know here
we are but it was just
it was just awful
to see and experience
but the also i guess the beautiful
to see in the experience if you're that
type of person and have the ability and
i'm lucky that i have the ability to
then parlay that feeling into something
tangible i'm lucky that my dad
you know the ultimate organizer i'm
lucky to have a brother that that
immediately stepped onto this and
started you know his part i'm lucky to
have the family and the support and you
know and i'm lucky to have the people
that would just ground me afterwards i
gave myself a couple of days and or a
week or whatever you know rehab with my
kid taking him to school and i'm back
i'm back where i feel like i need to be
he knew that he was in ukraine because
he'd been there a lot of times before
that i didn't let him watch anything and
he's too young to be able to see those
images and to really i didn't want him
to put him into a spot where
papa was in danger and to scare him like
there's no way i would do that so yeah
he was very sheltered
it was just another ukraine trip like
nothing out of the ordinary right
but prior to the
the experience i was
we were thinking i have a young son and
you know what is the background you know
how where the roots i'm just going to
continue on my journey with expanding
peter james beauty and hopefully we're
going to be able to go into makeup
products soon obviously focusing on my
son as well i'm pretty much a full-time
mum as well and yeah it did some dancing
and along the way i just want to be a
good dad and a great husband and you
know and after that it's whatever
the life throws at us right isn't it
funny i've been making all these plans
and we can all probably sit back and say
yeah soda have i for the last five years
i've been making plans we can tell you
that 90 of things we're doing today are
not things that we were planning so
let's just be open and
and hug a loved one
[Music]
you